professor Rivini thrilled to have you
back with us again this is not in the
textbooks what book is Draghi what book
is yelling what book are the elite here
what are they greeting from well it is
not in the books because six years after
the crisis we've tried zero policy rate
we've done quantitive easing we've done
credit easing we're done for our
guidance with him done negative deposit
rates and interested in nominal terms
have done unlimited and sterilized Forex
intervention and now last week they tiny
'treasure yields in Switzer my opinion
maturity where negative which from the
world is that now the gold bags were
saying that this is gonna lead to
collapse of the dollar i per inflation
because the gold is down the dollar is
up and with a problem with lack of
inflation of deflation because in spite
of these monetary steamers in my view
was not enough of fiscal stimulus right
and therefore output is still below
trends I spoke without imposing today at
the Peterson Institute he's looking for
bold moves and deflation would you
suggest mr. Draghi will be bold tomorrow
master Draghi wants to be bold he has to
go means a majority of the council to
surprise on the upside the trouble is to
have a larger program in terms of
sovereign bond purchases the hawks are
gonna say let's have leslie sharing and
have more of the national central bank
buying those bonds and if it accepts
less very sharing then it's not gonna be
as ninety percent of the people in this
valley and all of our viewers don't have
the sophistication you have honors when
you say there's a negative five-year
rate in japan when there's a negative
ten-year rate in switzerland we all
understand that's not normal is that
urgency there among the leads and
economics well they've been trying
they've tried to do everything possible
in order to try to avoid deflation the
problem is that we need not just the
right monetary policy and i've supported
unconventional monetary policy but QE
worked in the united states because he
had back loaded fiscal consolidation
while they've been front-loaded in the
case of the eurozone and structural
reform after curve in japan and eurozone
even the united states she have a 12 a
combination of policy and have not
right you were acclaimed for qe1 qe2 qe3
I put up the chart of said assets we're
still growing our asses which Huey are
we on right now well we finished the QE
3 and so far the Fed is saying that is
the economy recover at some point in
middle of the year Dubai Dubai that are
you with Vincent Reinhart formerly with
Morgan Stanley that they're gonna pull
it out if the rest of the world
surprises on the downside and if the
dollar sharply appreciate further at
spawn at some point the u.s. is not
going to be able to be careful from
what's happening in the rest the world
economic growth could slow down we could
go into deflation and in that case they
could postpone the start of the hike or
they could start hiking and then revert
themselves or in a very extreme scenario
they could go back to devising it's not
my baseline scenario but there is a
renewable code in your bloomberg
businessweek out it's your business code
I like it a lot the currency is the
thing your folks we're all linked here
two currencies when we travel or when
we're in the United States are we in a
currency war and when does the the
dollar become the Rubin strong dollar
we're not there yet are we not yet but
what's happened is the nicely the man is
weak because of the leveraging so
everybody wants to have stronger growth
with more net acts what that means a
weaker currency means more uncommon
chances it is and the latest run was
started by Japan after Japan did
additional qqe at the central bank in
Asia from China to Thailand to Korea
Taiwan and others down so another is
another run is going to start in Europe
we've the ECB there expand SMB the north
bank and everybody else but you are in
the world in which not everybody can
have a weaker currency my currencies
weak and some of this is stronger my
trade balance is better
some of the SS to be weaker so it's a
zero-sum game in currencies is a
zero-sum game in trade balances so there
is a currency war I want to switch here
to America we're going to talk about
that in the next section after the
president's State of the Union but
laughs couple nights ago I was in Zurich
and I stood outside the Swiss National
Bank late at night after a beverage of
my choice which I needed after what they
did this week nor Rubini on the effects
of what the Swiss National Bank did does
the in effect is it a butterfly flapping
that they're gonna feel in Peoria
Illinois maybe not in Peoria Illinois
but many other central banks were
not trying to avoid deflation by going
to a peg and a limited intervention on
the fax rate the Danish have done it the
checker diving it Israel and Sweden will
start to think along those lines and
what inseparably they send this signal
that even that last line of defense
against deflation may fail and if it's
gonna fail then what's called the anchor
for inflation expectation in Switzerland
in emerging market in advanced economies
therefore there is a global impact
Jeff sets a tough teacher it was a great
teacher there is this intractable issue
the president addressed it Republicans
address it America's inequality first of
all is it a legitimate topic or is it
always been there it's just something
visible now well inequalities worsening
in many advanced economies and
especially United States you have to ask
yourself why I think is because
technological innovation is capital
intensive and labor saving because trade
and globalization reduces the increment
jobs of those who have lost skills or
are partially skilled because where
these winner-take-all effects of the
superstars in any profession get the
benefits of a market of billions because
the economic and political power of
financial economic elite is great there
are lots of factors that are driving it
and is leading first to social political
instability but it also negative effects
economic growth because you are you
discipline the income from those who
spend more to those who save more so
over time they fall in the share of
labor income it's gonna have a negative
impact on economic growth and I read
that sounded like repeating 302 down in
New York University something like that
that was a great clinic what the
audience wants to know is how bad is the
plutocracy right now I mean within the
economics and the theory and all that
there's a behavioral construct here of
elites like in this valley how big is
the plutocracy effect in 2015 it's
significant because we're in a democracy
where is suppose it is to be one man and
one vote but the reality is those who
are billionaires those where economic
and financial power can affect
legislation on taxation of capital gains
of carried interests by having that
political power in u.s. we have a system
of legalized corruption if you think
about it K Street and the lobbying
effect legislation with the money to
give the politician and their
those were financial resources had a
greater impact on the political system
than those who have less so it's not a
to democracy what is a policy
prescription for Republicans dominant on
the hill who knows who will be in the
scene in 2016
you've been in the White House with the
intractable politics of this American
nation what's the prescription well last
night President Obama correctly said we
should tax slightly more the top one
percent and the financial institution
applause in applaud and they're not
gonna vote for it now they control the
Senate in addition to the house but the
problem is gonna be that even among
Republicans the middle class and the
working class who votes for Republicans
they're worried about the rising
inequality and therefore their chances
of winning 2016 are gonna be affected
Romney lost in part last time around
because he made the remarks about the
47% if that's gonna be the attitude of
the GOP is not that what would be good
for the name 2016 within the chart and
see iconic chart from two years ago
chart of the year which is median
household income adjusted inflation we
all know we've gone we've gone nowhere
and let's call it two decades is it a
technological solution that Phelps is
here the Columbia Columbia University
Nobel laureate he's waiting for a new
technology do you see it out there
technology actually makes things worse
because we were losing manufacturing
jobs and we created service jobs but now
services are becoming tradable and
therefore those service jobs are going
to emerging markets today their
ideologies move back and they do the
same job is there are girls in New York
for 1/4 of a salary but tomorrow they're
going to be a piece of software soon
replaced at the ORS in New York and
Mumbai so initially is offshoring of
these service jobs and manufacturing to
Asian emerging markets but eventually
technology and replace the jobs
altogether in transportation education
health care in retail in lots of
services so we are facing a long-term
problem Daniel Yergin here will speak to
him and are three days of coverage here
in Davos and oil Nora roubini right now
on the first and second order effects of
oil we all know it's good at the gas
pump but there's another story isn't
there an oil well there are
distributional effects exporters lose
importers of oil win with in countries
that produce all like us in China -
deucer lose and consumers are gaming but
the net impact for the global economy
and us is still positive because they
increase in disposable income and
consumption is gonna be greater than the
fall in output employment and capital
spending in the energy cycle is still a
net deposit if you wrap this up quickly
you and I said in that bar at the
Belvedere Hotel years ago talking about
the crisis to come if the crisis over is
not over look at the round the world the
eurozone is in deflation in a recession
Japan is not is not given by technology
oil is driven by lack of aggregate
demand in the US you can make this story
that technological innovation all prices
are leading to some degree of good
deflation but said that's not the story
for Japan for the eurozone and many
other parts of the world
he's a lack of a great demand and his
debt deflation is gonna make that
problems even worse
Nora beanie thank you so much wonderful
to have you here